Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich bin aus Asien, hier tätig und heute für Sie zu ständig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschichte für Sie zu tun.
Sie sind damit einverstanden.
Ja, gerne.
Ja, kurs für ablauf.
Verdeh ich Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person und dahten sich die Linien.
Dann werden wir sofort über Ihre Aktuellen Becher geben.
Wie heißt es Ihnen?
Ich heiße Oliver Baumann.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachname buchten?
Also Oliver wie O, L, I, V, E, R, Oliver.
Und Nachname Baumann, B, A, U, M, A, N, N Baumann.
Ja, okay, alles klar.
Herr Baumann, wie heißt es Ihnen?
Ich bin 62 Jahre alt.
Wann ist die genau geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 14.6.1961.
14.6., ich habe richtig verstanden.
14.6., 14. Juni, 1961.
Ja, okay. Wie groß und wie schlei sind Sie?
Wie groß bin ich ungefähr? 1,76 und wiege ungefähr 82 Kilo.
Ach, ist wieder okay, alles klar.
Was fühlt es dir uns? Was für Beschleiden haben Sie?
Was mich zu Ihnen fühlt.
Also, ich merke in den letzten paar Tagen habe ich mehr ein Gewicht zugenommen,
obwohl ich nicht mehr gegessen habe.
Und meine Beine fühlen sich dick an und meine Frau sagt,
auch mein Gesicht ist ein bisschen dicker geworden.
Ja.
Wie viel Kilo haben Sie abgenommen?
Ich habe nicht abgenommen, sondern ich habe zugenommen.
Okay, ich habe zugenommen.
Wie viel haben Sie zugenommen und in welcher Zeit?
Also innerhalb der letzten 4-5 Tage, vielleicht so 5 Kilo.
Okay.
Und sind beide Beine ist geschwollen, oder?
Ja, die Beine sind so ein bisschen geschwollen.
Also wenn ich so socken trage, dann schlören die sich da ein.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschleiden, zum Beispiel
Buschmeißen, Engelgefühl, Nussnoten, oder?
Was?
Vor allem, ich kann nicht mehr flach liegen.
Was immer bisher unproblematisch war, ich kann nachts nicht mehr flach liegen.
Ich kriege keine Luft, ich habe Angst zu ersticken.
Angst vorersticken.
Ja, okay.
Leiden Sie am Chronische vor Erkrankungen, wie Herzkrankheit
oder Bluthochdruck, oder?
Also Herzkrank war ich bisher nicht, ist mir nicht bekannt.
Bluthochdruck, bisschen hatte ich Bluthochdruck.
Ja, wobei mein Hausarzt immer gesagt hat, ich soll ein bisschen
Salz am Essen, dann wird das schon gehen.
Ja, achten Sie auf Ihre Ernährung.
Ich habe eigentlich immer geachtet, ja.
Ja, okay.
Sie hat Ihre Beschleiden grüßig aufgetreten oder langsam aufgetreten?
Das ist ganz langsam bekommen.
Langsamer.
Und hatten Sie in Läufe seit Verstehtheit oder Verstehtmann?
Was denn?
Ja, ich habe Ihre Schwierdung zugenommen.
Also innerhalb der letzten 4-5 Tage, das ist jetzt mehr und mehr geworden.
Okay.
Farbe verändern, an der Beine bemerk?
Nur Schwellungen mehr nicht.
Ja.
Okay.
Leider Sie unter Tollpreis getötet, misen erfündet oder kribbeln geführt an den Beinen?
Oder ihr Gezutro?
Nee, das habe ich nicht.
Früher hatten Sie Elische beschwertet?
Nee, früher hatte ich sowas als nie gehabt.
Ja.
Okay.
Farbe Sie Fieber?
Ja, Fieber habe ich nicht.
Aber manchmal habe ich den Eindruck, ich habe so, wieso ich das ausdrücken?
Manchmal als wenn ich Hitzewallungen hätte.
Hitzewallungen, ja.
Leider Sie unter Schütterausrost, Schütterausrost nach Schweiß oder...
Also, was meinen Sie mit Nachtschweiß?
Nachtschweiß.
Wie lange haben Sie das?
Ja, wenn Sie das so fragen, ja, in den letzten 2-3 Wochen ist das schon mehrmals vorbekommen, ja.
Ja.
Haben Sie Auflöser für Ihre Beschwerden bemerkt?
Noch mal bitte.
Auslöser?
Ja.
Nee, Auslöser sind mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen, ne?
Haben Sie dagegen etwas gemacht oder etwas eingehen, um wegen dieser Beschwerden?
Nein, nein, ich habe gedacht, das geht weg, aber es wird immer mehr und mehr,
deshalb bin ich jetzt hingefangen.
Ja, okay, mehr und...
Ja, okay.
Wie ist das Problem?
Also, wie jetzt in den letzten Tagen ist es so, ich komme kaum mehr treppen hoch,
so nach einem Stockwerk kann ich nicht mehr, da muss ich stehen bleiben.
Ja, stehen bleiben.
Ist Ihnen Schwindelig?
Nee, Schwindel habe ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Ja, okay.
Wie ist das Problem?
Bewusstseinsverlust, nee, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Okay.
Ich würde gerne sagen, wenn Sie an der Beine dürre, wie Sie das sagen,
diese Anschwerung ist ferschnittbar,
oder nach dem, wie Sie das sagen, verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Ja, wenn Sie die Schwerin an der Beine dürre,
macht das das Schüppel, oder wenn Sie weggehen, gibt es keinen Schüppel.
Also Sie können den Finger eindrücken, das bleibt dann bestehen.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Wasserlasten?
Wie oft gehen Sie zu Hause?
Aber Sie in der Beine dürfen das nicht, wenn Sie sich ändern?
Ja, ich habe den Eindruck, dass es ein bisschen weniger geworden ist.
Ja, können Sie bitte beschreiben, wie oft gehen Sie in welcher Menge?
Manche weiß ich nicht, habe ich nie gemessen, aber früher bin ich immer so
vier, fünf Mal am Tag, bin ich immer zur Toilette gegangen.
Letzte Zeit habe ich gemerkt, so zweimal, dreimal, maximal, mehr nicht.
Und es kommt auch nicht viel.
Das kommt nicht viel.
Welche Reime hat Ihr Öre Wasserlasten?
Das ist gelb, rischbräunig oder dunkelbräunig.
Also das ist ganz hell.
Okay.
Wie viel Wasser trinken Sie gegen?
Also ich bin eigentlich immer ein guter Trinkler, ich habe jeden Tag immer so
drei Liter, dreieinhalb Liter einmal getrunken.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihr Studant?
Haben Sie Verstopfung oder Durchfall?
Nein, weder noch.
Ja, okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Also mein Appetit ist jetzt in den letzten zwei, drei Tagen ein bisschen schlechter geworden,
aber sonst habe ich immer einen guten Appetit gehabt.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Ja, so leicht, jetzt in den paar Tagen, aber sonst habe ich so etwas nicht gehabt.
Haben Sie schon erbrochen?
Nein, erbrechen habe ich nicht gehabt.
Okay.
Wie fühlen Sie in der letzten Zeit müde oder leiden Sie Kraftlösigkeit?
Noch mal, ich habe Sie nicht verstanden.
Wie fühlen Sie in der nächsten Zeit leiden Sie unter Kraftlösigkeit oder?
Ja, so richtig Kraftlösigkeit, aber ich habe den Eindruck, meine Muskeln schwächeln ein bisschen.
Muskel schwächeln.
Okay.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben schon erbrechen, Sie haben ein bisschen erbrechte Blutdruck.
Sie müssen in einer Bakterung, ohne Sass, haben Sie so andere Erkrankungen?
Nein, ohne andere Erkrankungen, ich bin nicht bekannt.
Okay, sehr gut.
Wie fühlen Sie die Medikamente ein?
Ich nehme momentan keine Medikamente ein.
Okay.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, am Blinddarm, das war eine Kindheit, 30, 40 Jahre.
Okay.
Das war es, nicht?
Blinddarm?
Ja, noch andere Operationen.
Sonst keine andere Operation.
Okay.
Wie sind Sie, gab es Komplikationen während der Odenachter-Operationen?
Nein, das war ein harmloser Eingriff, hat man damals gesagt.
Das ist relativ schnell abgehalten.
Okay, okay.
Ist Ihnen allergien beklagt?
Nein, nicht, dass ich öste.
Okay, gut.
Sie ist in Verständung geimpft?
Was meine Sie in Verständung geimpft?
Ich meine Corona und Kindheit-Impfungen.
Also die Kindheit-Impfungen sind alle gemacht und Corona auch, na klar?
Okay.
Warst du im Ausland in der nächsten Saison oder hatte du eine Range Reise?
Nein, ich war weder im Ausland noch hatte ich eine Reise.
Okay. Ich würde gerne jetzt ein paar Fragen zu Ira Gemann heute stellen.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Baumann?
Ich habe mal geraucht, aber es ist jetzt 30 Jahre her. Ich rauche seither nicht mehr.
Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen.
Wie viel Zigarette haben Sie früher geraucht?
Also ich habe vielleicht nur fünf Jahre geraucht insgesamt und am Tag waren es vielleicht so 20 Zigaretten.
Okay, alles klar. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ganz selten, vielleicht ein, zwei Mal im Jahr zu feierlichen Anläs.
Okay, okay.
Mit der nächsten Frage nicht, persönlich, dass eine Routine Frage, die ich jede Patientin fragen muss, haben Sie Kontakt mit Rauchen?
Nein, nein.
Mit Rauchen habe ich nichts an Rauchen.
Okay.
Ich würde gerne jetzt ein paar Fragen zu Ira Gemann.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Bitte nochmal.
Ja, ja, die leben noch.
Leiden Ihre Eltern an irgendwelche Erkrankungen,
Visukarkrankheit, Herzkrankheit oder Bluthochturup erst mal Ihres Vater?
Ja, natürlich. Die sind nicht mehr die jüngsten. Mein Vater leidet ein Diabetes.
Es war so ein Zweier, jetzt muss er insulin spritzen.
Darüber hinaus hat er mit der Prost-Aterprobleme.
Die Mutter hat mal mit der Prost-Anprobleme gehabt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Krebs war oder gutartig.
Dann hat sie auch noch einen Schlaganfall gehabt.
Sie hat auch Bluthochdruck.
So wie das so im Leben ist, die Eltern, die werden, dass sie mehr Krankheiten kommen zur Tage.
Okay, okay.
Okay, ich habe verstanden. Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin in einem Wirtschaftsunternehmen als Ingenieur tätig.
Sind Sie zufrieden mit der Arbeit oder haben Sie Schütter?
Nein, ich habe keinen Stress. Ich mache den Job sehr gerne.
Wie ist Ihre Familie statt?
Ich bin feierer.
Okay, haben Sie Leben mit Ihrer Familie?
Ja, ich lebe mit meiner Frau zusammen. Das ist richtig.
Okay, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei Söhne und eine Tochter, aber die sind schon alle außer Haus.
Sie sind schon alle erwachsen, haben selber Familien.
Die sind nicht mehr unter uns.
Okay, sind Sie gesund?
Sie sind gesund, die haben keine Probleme.
Okay, super.
Okay, haben Sie Internetseiseit, Hautfarbe, Veränderungen, zum Beispiel, gelbe Haut oder?
Das weiß ich nicht. Hab ich jetzt nicht drauf geachtet.
Okay, haben Sie Ihr Blutdruck gemessen, schon?
Nein, ich habe ja bisher nie so richtig Probleme damit gehabt.
Ich habe den Blutdruck jetzt nicht gemessen.
Okay, haben Sie Frigah Probleme bei Schilddröse?
Mit der Schilddröse Probleme ist mir nicht bekannt.
Nein, es ist nicht bekannt.
Ja, okay.
Ich habe meine Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ich fahre dem Hut darauf, dass man mir hilft und mir sagt, was los ist.
Ich kenne meinen Körper nicht mehr wieder.
Ja, ich ergele Ihnen jetzt, was wir machen zu.
Erst mal ist es so, für mich etwas zu sagen.
Soll abkühlen, brauche ich noch einmal Untersuchungen.
Ich werde Sie erst mal körperlich untersuchen.
Dann messe ich Ihre Bitterparameter.
Ich meine, ich habe Blutdruck, Atemfökern, Herzfökern.
Dann schreibe ich ein EKG und nehme Blut ab.
Nach der EKG kann ich Ihnen eine Eiserade.
Okay, gut. Ein Verstatt.
Ja, okay. Bitte nehmen Sie Platz.
Ich rühre Sie Sie gleich.
Alles klar.
Ja.
Was gibt es andere Fragen?
Kann ich fragen?
Ja, fragen Sie.
Ja, danke. Bezüglich Ihre geschwollenen Beine,
wollte ich fragen, ob die Schwelungen erbilden Sie zurück
oder sind Sie immer da?
Tagesüber?
Sie sind jetzt immer da.
Sie lassen sich nicht mehr wegdrücken.
Sie gehen auch nicht weg.
Hallo Herr Baumann.
Und husten Sie?
Nein.
Hallo?
Ja? Nein.
Haben Sie Brotschmerz?
Nein.
IDEE
Frage, ein anderer Kollegen, bitte.
Danke.
Hallo Herr Baumann.
Haben Sie zunehmende Bauchumfang bemerkt
oder ist Ihnen Jürgen aufgefallen?
Also der Haut juckt schon so ein bisschen, aber Baurempfangsvermehrung habe ich jetzt nicht so richtig bemerkt.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Haben Sie bisher Probleme mit Prostate?
Mit der Prosta da, Problem.
Genau.
Nee, ist bisher nicht gewesen, nein.
Okay.
Hallo Herr Bohrmann, ich habe einige Fragen.
Hatten Sie vor einem Monat irgendwelche Erkältung oder Viraleinfektionen?
Ja, eine Infektion nicht.
Vor einem Monat, da muss ich mal überlegen.
Innerhalb.
Nein, kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig irgendwelche Nahrungsergänzungen mit Tell?
Nahrungsergänzungen mit Tell?
Nein, das ist ganz normal.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass ich irgendwelche Vorteile von Nahrungsergänzungen habe.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Noch andere Kollegen, kontrollieren Sie Ihre Gesundheit regelmäßig, Herr Bohrmann?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Zum Beispiel jeden sechs Monat oder ein Jahr ich Laboruntersuchung oder Australieruntersuchung machen.
Also ich bin vor einem Jahr mal zum Urologen gegangen, zur Prostatekontrolle.
Das ist aber auch alles, sonst habe ich keine Probleme, sonst bin ich kein Arztgänger.
Herr Bohrmann, leiden Sie am Herbst?
Ich habe Herzrasen und Herzgepraktung, ich weiß nicht, aber Herzrasen und Herzstöte.
Also Herzrasen habe ich jetzt nicht bemerkt, nein, und sonst habe ich auch keine Probleme mit dem Herz.
Ich habe eigentlich auch immer wieder mal ein bisschen Sport gemacht.
Ich war sehr gerne Fahrrad, auch mal so 20 Kilometer am Tag, am Wochenende, wenn ich Zeit habe.
Also ich habe bisher keine solche Probleme gehabt.
Okay.
Ja.
Ja, das ist ja nicht abgeschrieben.
Okay.
Wie wollen wir das machen?
Hallo Oberlas, ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich werde Ihnen vorstellen, da hätten Sie gesagt.
Kann ich den Patienten vorstellen, während die richtige Frage.
Okay.
Ja, klar, gerne.
Der Patient heißt Oliver Bohrmann.
Herr Bohrmann ist 2,60 Jahre alt, geboren am 14.06.1961, 1,78 m groß, 2,80 kg.
Herr Bohrmann hat sich bei uns seit 6 Tagen wegen der probedierten Langsamaufgetretene
an der Beine und im Geset vorgestellt.
An der Beine.
Ja, auf vorgestellt.
Die Beschwerden seien langsam aufgetreten und hätten sich Igbler-Fesal zugenommen.
Der Patient krackte über leichte Übungen ohne Erbrechen und Urgüro.
Die Frage nach FIBA, der Patient krackte über Überkeit,
über Leichte Überkeit ohne Erbrechen und Urgüro.
Die Frage nach FIBA, der Patient krackte über Überleichte Übungen ohne Erbrechen
und Urgüro.
Die Frage nach FIBA, der Patient krackte über Überleichte
Überleichte Übungen ohne Erbrechen und Urgüro.
Ich höre Herz und Rungen ab und ich messe die Beine umfack.
Ich schreibe ein E-Karke, ob eine Herzstöße ist.
Dann nehme ich Blutab,
bei Blut ich möchte Blutbild, CRP, Blutsuka, Elektrolyde,
Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Prübenen,
und Herzenzyme.
Ich möchte eine Echokardiografie
und Duplexsonongriffe an den Beinen durchführen.
Ich möchte auch D-Dimer schauen im Bild.
Sehr gut. Warum D-Dimera?
Eine T-Aft und Rungenödemefallschilis auszuschließen.
Er war nicht auf Reisen,
und hat keine Reise an einem Nese.
Er war nicht beträgerisch.
Er hat für ihn keine ähnliche Beschwerden.
Wie schätzen Sie die Wahrscheinlichkeit
für eine Trombose oder Lungenembolie?
Nicht laut, sondern niedrig.
Sie können das nicht falsch machen,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass der eine Lungenembolie hat,
wie das Schilder.
Er war keine Reise,
er war keine Plattenausfall,
keine Reingerise, keine Magnetität.
Sehr gut.
Jetzt haben Sie den untersucht.
Sie haben tatsächlich gesehen,
er hat an den Unterschenkeln schon eindrucksbare Udeme.
Er hat eindrucksbare Udeme.
Sie merken, er könnte auch ein bisschen Anasake haben,
nicht nur an den Unterschenkeln,
sondern das Ganze kann auch in die Bauchdecke
ein bisschen ödematös geschwollen sein.
Anasaka könnte er auch haben.
Wenn Sie den abhören,
hören Sie da in den Lungenbasalen Abschnitten,
hören Sie da irgendwelche Rasselgeräusche?
Ja, ich höre Rasselgeräusche,
weidegehüge, wegen Ödeme.
Den sollten Sie vielleicht mal röntgen,
um zu sehen, inwieweit das ausgeprägte Ägystusel,
um ein Ultraschall machen,
ein Chlorazono machen, um zu gucken,
ob das irgendeine punktabler Ägyste sind oder nicht,
ob sich das lohnt oder nicht.
Man kann es auch diagnostisch einmal punktieren
und nachschauen, ob das ein Trans-Sodat
oder ein Ex-Sodat ist.
Als Assistenzärztin in der Torax-Klinik
müssten Sie das erkennen.
Ja.
Im EKG, was ist Ihnen da aufgefallen?
Ja, kann ich im EKG,
kann man erst mal,
wie man das sieht,
beurteilen,
schauen,
wie man das mit dem EKG nicht erfüllt ist.
Das ist ein ganz normaler regelmäßiger Sinus-Rhythmus.
Keine Erregungsrückbewegung,
das ist ein ganz normaler Rhythmus.
Das ist ein ganz normaler regelmäßiger Sinus-Rhythmus.
Keine Erregungsrückbildung, Störungen
und keine Blockbildungen.
Also das ist ein ganz normales EKG.
Ist es auch nicht irgendwie atypisch
oder irgendwie anders konfiguriert?
Im EKG sehen Sie nichts Auffälliges.
Was machen Sie dann?
Eho-Carbography.
Ich messe Ethiksohne.
Können Sie machen, aber bevor Sie gleich
in die ganz spezielle Untersuchung gehen,
denken Sie allgemein,
wenn so jemand zum Beispiel in die Notaufnahmen
oder auf die Station kommt,
dann hat der entweder schon Blut abgegeben
oder Sie müssen erst mal Blut abnehmen,
gucken, wohin geht das Ganze überhaupt.
Das sich erst mal ein Bild von dem Patient machen.
Was haben Sie vor sich?
Was sehen Sie da?
Blut abnehmen.
Also das Allerwichtigste ist, Sie müssen Schritt für Schritt vorgehen.
Sie machen eine Herzkörper-Untersuchung.
Was Sie gesagt haben,
Sie schreiben einen EKG.
Ein Unterschreib vom Bauch.
Können Sie gerne noch machen
und die Labor-Untersuchung ist sehr, sehr wichtig.
Das sind die breit elementaren Dinge.
Und dann röntgen können Sie noch machen
und dann können Sie sich schon ein Bild machen,
was der Patient überhaupt haben könnte.
Und dann erst kommen die weiterführenden,
spezifischen Untersuchungen.
Wenn Sie denken, das ist ein kardiales Problem,
dann machen Sie eine Echokardiopathy.
Wenn Sie denken, das ist ein anderes Problem,
dann verlieben Sie sich in diese Richtung.
EKG haben wir geguckt, da ist nichts.
Da erwarte ich jetzt aber nichts am Herzen.
Echo ist sicherlich nicht schlecht,
aber nicht zu diesem Zeitpunkt das Richtige, würde ich sagen.
Sie gucken erst mal mit dem Urteil schal.
Wie sieht es da aus?
Wenn am Herzen nichts ist,
weshalb kann man sonst noch Udeme haben
oder Anasaka haben?
Ja, weil der Eiweißmengel war Hipoalben,
die sind ja auch auf die Leberkrankheiten.
Ja, die Leberkrankheiten.
Und ich in jeder Leberkrankheit mache es auch öfter.
Sehr gut. Darum geht es jetzt.
Das ist ja einmal die Bauchorgane angucken
und schauen, ob zum Beispiel ein Nierenstau da ist,
ob zum Beispiel die Leber zerrottisch umgebaut ist
oder vielleicht doch ein Tumor in der Leber drinsetzt.
Danach einmal schauen, gucken.
Ultraschall.
Und Sie sehen, dass es in der Leberkrankheit
ein bisschen wie ein Ultraschall ist.
Und Sie sehen, im Ultraschall hat der Mann
ein bisschen Wasser im Bauch, also Acetes,
aber die Nieren sehen blander aus
und die Leber ist völlig normal konfiguriert.
Vielleicht ein Ticken, Stiatosis Hepatis,
also so eine Fetleber,
aber sonst sehen Sie nichts auffälliges.
Und was machen Sie dann?
Jetzt gucken Sie sich die Laborwerte an.
Und in Labor sehen Sie...
Ja, sagen Sie, was wir gucken,
dass Sie das lernen.
Einweis und probieren die Nierenwerte,
Leberwerte,
Erstöderste.
Und also, was Sie sehen,
Natrium ist fast normal
und Kalium ist ein bisschen erhöht
mit 6,0
und Kreatinien ist so bei 4,6
Harnstoff um die 160,
Harnsäure 12,0
und Leberwerte sind so ein bisschen angestiegen
und CRP ist fast bei 0.
Und Blutbild ist völlig normal.
Ja, ich denke,
övulimische...
Ich denke,
ADH-Synron kann man sagen, oder?
Antidür?
Antidür.
Ja, Sie werden da, müssen Sie sagen,
Symptom der inadequateen ADH-Sekretion,
SEADH.
Aber was fällt denn allererstes auf?
Nicht gleich an die Ursache gehen, es fällt Ihnen auf,
das ist ein abgutiges Nierenversagen.
Sie sehen erst mal ein Nierenversagenkost.
Was die Ursache des Nierenversagens ist,
der ist man nicht.
Eine Sekunde, ich muss mal grad...
Gut, Entschuldigung.
Also akutes Nierenversagen.
Und jetzt müssen wir uns langsam an die Sache heranarbeiten.
Was ist es?
Wenn wir jetzt ein akutes Nierenversagen haben,
was fällt Ihnen dann als Ursache für ein akutes Nierenversagen
dann so ein?
Wenn wir jetzt ein paar Lettermtage haben,
kann das eine, man sagt ein prärenales Nierenversagen sein?
Also Hypovolemie, kann das sein?
Er wahrscheinlich nicht.
Was kann es sein?
Wir haben eine Medikamente gefragt,
er nimmt keine Medikamente.
Und die Infektion, die Infektion geht sich da auch gefragt,
wegen der Dokus, weil manchmal
kontestunierenversagen fühlen?
Ja, sehr gut.
Was gibt es noch?
Also Sie können ja auch zählen, zum Beispiel.
Das haben wir schon richtig alles gefragt.
Es gibt natürlich eine Hypertunierung,
die nicht bedingt ist, also Nephrosklerose.
Sie können eine diabetesische Nefropathie haben.
Sie können eine arzneimitteltoxische Nefropathie haben.
Sie können eine infektinduzierte Nefropathie haben.
Was können Sie aber auch noch haben?
Eine autoimmunnefropathie.
Das kann es manchmal auch geben.
Und das merkwürdige,
weiter autoimmunnefropathie ist,
die Leute haben kein Fieber, kein Schüttelfrost,
gar nichts.
Deswegen kann man den Leuten nicht ansehen,
ob das jetzt irgendwie infektinduziert ist oder nicht.
Jetzt müssen wir Schritt für Schritt alles einmal abklären.
Was von dem passt zu diesen Menschen?
Der hat keinen Infekt gehabt, der hat B is null.
Aber trotzdem sollten Sie bei diesen Menschen
nach gängigen Viren einmal nachgucken.
Hier in Deutschland gibt es einen Virus,
der ganz besonders
sogenannte Niereninsuffizienzen macht,
akute Niereninsuffizienzen.
Haben Sie von dem schon mal gehört,
ein Virus, der das manchmal so macht?
Der Hunter-Virus.
Hunter-Viren sind vor allem in Ratten
oder in Mäusekurt enthalten.
Wenn die Leute im Garten mal
mit der Hand arbeiten und so weiter,
dann können Sie diese Viren aufnehmen.
Diese Viren machen eine extrem verschlechtete
Nierenfunktion.
Die können ein bisschen zu Intensivpflichtigkeit
kommen, kürzlich werden.
Es kann sogar passieren, dass das tödlich verlor.
Ich habe erst mal gehört.
Das ist eine akute Form.
Hunter-Virus.
Hunter-Virus noch nie gehört.
Das ist hier in Deutschland sehr weit verbreitet.
Das ist ja nicht vergessen.
Das ist manchmal regional sehr häufig vorhanden.
Hunter-Viren machen akute Niereninsuffizienzen.
Danach sollte man einmal schon sämtliche Viren nachgucken.
Die können alle die Nieren schädigen.
Eine akute Niereninsuffizienz kann natürlich ausgelöst werden.
Auch bakterielle Infektionen,
ohne dass man es merkt.
Aber das ist bei den Menschen natürlich eher ungewöhnlich.
Die sind normal.
ZRP ist normal.
Das ist eine bakterielle Infektion.
Die Abete ist schon mal gesagt.
Nein, die Patronie ist auch nicht.
Wie können Sie eine Autoimmunenepfritis mehr oder weniger abklären?
Mit Gewebeprobe.
Ja, bevor Sie aber an die Gewebeprobe.
Das ist sicherlich sehr wichtig.
Das kommt aber als letzter Schritt.
Was sollte man noch machen?
Antikörper in Ruht bestimmen.
Welche Antikörper sind es?
Dann fahre ich mal so.
Ja, das ist nicht ein Antikörper.
Man kann z.B. P-Anker, C-Anker bestimmen.
Ja, P-Anker.
Ja, P-Anker, C-Anker-Werte können Sie bestimmen.
Sie können auch natürlich die Immunglobuline bestimmen.
Eins haben wir natürlich vergessen.
Was kann dann auch eine Niereninsuffizienz auslösen?
Ein Multiplismylom oder eine Aminoidosa.
Ein Multiplismylom
kann natürlich Leichketten produzieren.
Wie genannte Benz-Jones-Potene,
die dann die Nierenfilter kaputt machen
und dann eine Niereninsuffizienz auslösen.
Oder aber die Leichkettenkrankheit,
die Leichkettenaminoidosa,
die kann auch eine Niereninsuffizienz auslösen.
Und die Myolomekrankung können Sie im Blut erkennen.
Wenn Sie einfach eine Serumelektrophorese machen,
eine Gammazacke erkennen,
einen M-Gradienten in der Gammazacke
und auch noch eine Immunfixation machen,
dann sehen Sie, ob da vielleicht ein Myolom vorhanden ist
oder nicht.
Wenn das nicht der Fall ist, bleibt Ihnen nichts anderes übrig.
Als tatsächlich in die Niere einmal reinzustecken.
Aber Sie haben bei diesen Menschen ja P-Anker
und C-Anker abgenommen.
Und dann sehen Sie, dieser Mensch hat erhöhte P-Ankerwerte.
Was sagt uns das jetzt?
Hallo?
Ja, ja, ich weiß schon. Aber ich habe vergessen.
Sie haben nicht. Ich dachte, die Verbindung ist weg.
Deswegen habe ich es nochmal nachgefragt.
Wichtig ist, Sie haben jetzt P-Anker.
Und das ist für Sie eine P-Anker-induzierte Nephropathie.
Und das ist mehr oder weniger eine Autoimmunkrankheit.
Und jetzt müssen Sie wieder gegenvorgehen.
Was machen Sie als nächsten Schritt?
Ja, Telepee.
Telepee ist so, oder?
Ja, eigentlich sehr gut.
Sie sind kein Facharzt für Nierenkrankheiten.
Konzil auf, nephrologisch.
Konzil, ne? Ein nephrologisches Konzilantroiter.
Sie müssen ganz dringend den Patienten urologisch oder nephrologisch vorstellen.
Und sagen, hier, ich habe all das gemacht
und seht her, dieser Mensch hat irgendwie eine P-Anker-induzierte Nephropathie.
Und eine P-Anker-Induzierte Nephrologie muss sich alles gemeinsam angucken
und davon ableiten, was zu tun ist oder nicht.
Bei Niereninsuffizienz muss man noch zwei, drei Dinge genau angucken.
Wissen Sie, was das vielleicht so sein könnte?
Was ist mit einer Niereninsuffizienz immer so ein bisschen verbunden?
Ich hatte gesagt, der Mann hat ein Kalium von sechs.
Worauf sollte man noch achten bei der Niereninsuffizienz?
Ja, Paratomol.
Paratomol sollte man einmal angucken.
Ja, Kalzium sollte man angucken,
Phosphat sollte man angucken und Kalzitriol sollte man nochmal angucken.
Weil mit einer Niereninsuffizienz kommt diese Achse einmal durcheinander
und damit dieser Mensch nicht diese Probleme hat.
Sie stellen diesen Menschen jetzt nephrologisch vor.
Was müsst ihr aber mit diesem Herrn noch machen in dem Fall?
Er hat einen Kalium von sechs. Warten Sie einfach zu.
Was soll mit dem jetzt passieren?
Nein, ich gebe Zuka-Lösung mit Ilzirin.
Und Kalium wird Ilzirin.
Ja, wie viel geben Sie denn da, wenn ich so fragen darf?
Ich muss erstmal Brut Zuka konzentrieren.
Ich erinnere nicht die Einheit.
Ja, der hat einen ganz normalen Zucker.
Wie viel, was geben Sie ihm jetzt?
Was geben Sie an Glucoso und wie viel ihn so gehen?
Ja, weiß ich nicht die Einheit.
Ich persönlich, das ist jetzt meine Regel.
Ich habe immer die Zweierregel immer angewendet.
Wenn es mal so etwas kam, dazu gehört 200 Milliliter.
Milliliter Glucose 10 plus 10 Einheiten.
10 Einheiten, okay, 10 Einheiten.
Ja, in zwei Stunden. Also 200 Milliliter Glucose 10.
10 Einheiten, die können auch 20 Einheiten geben,
müssen nicht schlimm, an Aktrapid oder Novorapid
und dann in zwei Stunden reinlaufen lassen.
Aber, die dürfen eins nicht vergessen.
Dieser Mensch hatte einen Haarstoff von 160, 170.
Er hatte einen Kallium von fast 6 und der hat einen Kreatinien von 4,6.
Was sollten Sie mit diesen Menschen machen in dem Falle?
Die Diuretika, ich kann die Diuretika geben oder Blutwäsche.
Ja, wo wird denn so eine Blutwäsche gemacht?
Eine Dialyse, wo wird es gemacht? Auf der Intensivstation.
Ja, ja, für ja, Brat, der hat eine Stange,
eine, was ich immer aufs Tor kenne, Katheten, Katheten, ja.
Für die Förder.
Ja, aber soweit sind wir noch nicht.
Das ist auch nicht Ihre Aufgabe.
Das soll die Intensivstation machen.
Sie müssen einfach nur die Indikation stellen.
Den Patienten geht es nicht gut.
Die Nierenwerte sind nicht gut.
Der hat ein Haarstoff, Kallium ist irgendwie sehr, sehr hoch.
Und sie rufen einfach auf die Intensivstation an,
nachdem sie mit ihrem Oberarzt gesprochen haben und sagen,
dieser Mann, der gehört auf die Intensivstation.
Der kann Herzrhythmischstörungen bekommen,
der kann alles Mögliche bekommen, der schadet nicht mehr richtig aus
und der muss auf die Intensivstation eingestellt überwacht werden.
Und dann dem Katheter legen oder die sagen,
Braunüle reicht erst mal aus, das soll in die selber entscheiden.
Also, ich habe auch ein bisschen auf die Intensivstation gearbeitet.
Ich weiß, dass man bei solchen Patienten nicht sofort
mit einer Dialyse reingeht.
Man gibt erst mal viel Theoretiker und man kippt Wasser trotzdem rein,
auch wenn die Oedema haben oder nicht,
wenn das Herz richtig gut pumpt.
Dafür ist dann die Echokardiografie gut geeignet.
Und dann wartet man erst mal zu.
Und wenn der Nephrodokel kommt und sieht,
ja, per Anker induzierte Nephropathie und das ist eine Autoimmunnephritis,
dann wird er noch sagen, ja, gib dem mal 250 Cortison täglich dazu.
Und bevor man das Markt auch nochmal eine Mierenbiopsy,
damit man das Ganze auch spheologisch nochmal gesichert hat,
das ist aber Sache des Nephrodokeln.
Und dann haben Sie das Paket rundum fertig.
Haben Sie schon mal so einen Fall gehört?
Haben Sie damit mal etwas zu tun gehabt?
Ja, wenigstens habe ich gehört.
Okay, okay, gut.
Ich habe die Patienten mit Beinen und Rungen da,
die haben diese Patienten so behandelt in Deiner Träufer.
Ich habe so viel gesehen.
Ja, sehr gut.
Sie sehen, das kommt, also eine Niereninsuffizienz akut,
kann tatsächlich zu einer hydropen Dekompensation führen.
Und da müssen Sie einfach nur Schritt für Schritt arbeiten,
einfach logisch nachdenken, was kann kommen, woher, wieso und weshalb.
Und Sie können vieles parallel machen,
dann können Sie diesen Menschen auch relativ rasch helfen.
Ja, und ich hatte auch mal vor geraumer Zeit so einen Patienten gehabt
und die hatten, die Kardologen hatten den aufgenommen,
hatten am ersten Moment auch richtig gedacht,
ob das auch eine Autoimmunnefritis sein kann,
haben alles Mögliche an Viren, Serologie und auch Panker, Canker, alles abgenommen.
Und weil der Mensch durch diese Niereninsuffizienz
auch eine pathologische Elektrophorese hatte,
hatten Sie den dann zu uns geschickt mit der Frage,
ob der Mülum haben kann oder nicht.
Das Dumme war aber die Immunfixation, die war unauffällig.
Ja, und damit haben Sie einen Mülum ausgeschlossen.
Und dann habe ich mir alles nochmal genauer angeguckt
und habe dann gesehen, der ist doch per Anker positiv.
Der hat doch ein Autoimmunnefritis.
Und da schon mal bei uns, da habe ich den gesagt,
da müssen wir noch eine Amyloidose ausschließen,
haben ihn dann nochmal Beckenkampen punktiert
und haben ihn dann, wir haben ihn dann tatsächlich zur Nierenbürbsee geschickt
und der Pathologe rief dann sofort an und meinte,
das ist eine per Anker induzierte Nephropathie.
Ganz schnell.
Und dann haben wir gesagt, der muss in eine nephrologische Klinik.
Und den haben wir dann einfach dorthin verlegt.
Ja, also so schnell kann das kommen.
Okay?
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?